formidable accueil populaire pourtant
soit différente
accueil dont le maroc top secret
l'aéroport de rabat salé ils ont tenté
de défiler des centaines de km2 et
profanes
comment ça marche
c'est le premier voyage officiel de
françois dupeyron
bravo
drôle de question antiquités
pas nous
il
deuxième temps fort de cette journée là
steria la chambre des représentants
c'est à dire le parlement du pays où
siègent les élus au suffrage universel
du peuple marocain d'ailleurs les
prochaines élections législatives sont
prévues au printemps de cette année
c'est devant les députés marocains de
toutes les tendances politiques françois
mitterrand a choisi d'adresser son
premier discours officiel
une façon pour le président de la
république française de marquer son
attachement aux libertés à la démocratie
et au respect des droits de l'homme
alors vous savez que le maroc est une
monarchie constitutionnelle qui a
toujours respecté une certaine
démocratie mais une démocratie en
liberté surveillée et qui a varié
souvent selon le bon vouloir du roi
hassan ii mais on assiste et c'est
indéniable depuis six mois ici à une
libéralisation du régime
et cette libéralisation a beaucoup
facilité les rapports entre paris et
rabat il y at il enfin bien plus
précieux
messieurs que la liberté pour les
peuples comme pour les individus vous
marocain qui est pénétrée de notre
histoire connaissait l'importance du
legs de 1789 universel autant que
français et de la déclaration des droits
de l'homme
oh certes la france n'a pas à s'ériger
et ne s'érige pas en juge des uns des
autres dont les situations diffèrent
mais autoriser le président d'un pays
ami à se réjouir des promesses que
contient votre constitution et des
perspectives
aujourd'hui tracé mais dans le monde
actuel ces grands principes n'auront ni
fondement solide ni traduction concrète
ci n'est pas assurée le droit au
développement